that's what I think the Iraq war has
failed miserably is that democracy is
not just about elections is about
institutions it's about civil liberties
is about all of these good education
good infrastructure that was not I mean
and that was not built even though some
may argue that was the intention of the
war but as you dig in more and you see
the corruption between the contractors
and other contractors and suddenly just
the money disappears for some reason
which was all meant for kind of
rebuilding institutions I struggle with
these questions I may not really have
the best answer to them but I think is
that it all depends what you value if
what you value for example when a chive
alyou is for some freedom of information
yes iraq is doing much better in terms
of information they have much more
accessibility to information so if you
want to democratize or move the society
to become more accepting of
enlightenment values or or any values
that you'd like to promote iraq is more
suitable for it now than it used to 2003
the same way syria I mean Sierra now is
under Assad is equivalent to what it
used to be in terms of authoritarianism
on information so it all depends what
you value if you value safety Saddam
Hussein some were much safer but how did
he kept the safe by putting people in
the gulag who-ville under gulag I mean
that I mean that's its authoritarian
safety it's not like safety as and
everybody getting along but it's more
like if you speak your mind you're gonna
get killed so of course you can get
safety so safe so it's but you get a lot
of pushback when you say that sort of
thing right when you say that that Iraq
now even though Iraq is obviously still
a mess and there was that brief moment
and I do want to focus on a little bit
that brief moment where there were free
and fair election you know basically
free and round and the whole world saw
it but then the u.s. under Obama just
pulled out just like that and then
things got much worse but at that little
moment when there were the elections do
you think more people were thinking like
you just said because I see you say this
sort of thing right now but America has
sort of freed Iraq in a lot of ways and
then I see the amount of hate that you
get from yeah usually unfortunately from
the lefties I mean again is this so I
mean I'm as I
grow older cousin quote is that I think
is that even these fair elections
elections at the time were were not
necessarily the best idea because this
is a country that was devastated by
multiple Wars many of the people are
either sectarian are live in less
education so it in a way that the fair
elections are the elections has enhanced
sectarianism more than introduced it's
because many of the people who are Shias
let's save voted for Shia parties and
certainly support for Senate parties and
Kurds worse than the Kurds but and so as
I as I now think about it is that it's a
democracy which I think that's where I
think the Iraq war has failed miserably
is that democracy is not just about
elections is about institutions it's
about civil liberties is about all of
these good education good infrastructure
that was not I mean and that was not
built even though some may argue that
was the intention of the war but as you
dig in more and you see the corruption
between the contractors and other
contractors and suddenly just the money
disappears for some reason which was all
meant for kind of rebuilding
institutions that is I think what was
really missing because I think were we
on the path until we left right so you
had elections I get what you're saying
no could create a mess because
everyone's just gonna vote for their own
home parties like yeah yeah but were we
sort of on the path and then just
magically left and then I mean the word
role was I think even Democrats that
I've talked to and who are supportive
thing as a disaster is that I mean the
one of the things that they you I mean I
was at the time in Iraq as well is that
the US was doing with with with there's
a movement called awakening forces which
are Sunni militias fight against
al-qaeda it was kind of acting as a
neutral force between all of these
because the shares don't see the
Americans ashiya's or Sunnis they see
them as Americans so or vice versa
right so the tribes for example were
willing more the Sunni tribes were more
willing to work with Americans that they
were willing with their work with the
Iraqis with the Rajesh's because they
think the Iraqi shares are affiliated
with Iran which is their internal enemy
so in a way America was acting as a kind
of a neutral force that keeps all of
these people together
and the moment that disappeared with
witches from the withdrawal which was
amazing in the unplanned they arrived
government will do a sectarian at the
time and in a way still is immediately
pull out the funding from all of the
Sunnis in what fighting against Al Qaeda
so many so so when that happened
immediately the these guys who were
fighting against Al Qaeda certainly
they're becoming a target to to still
the sleeping cell sleeper cells of the
terrorist group or they're like okay
what we're gonna fight for anymore so
then suddenly Isis comes up what a
surprise so so so for those who actually
followed Iraq from all of the beginning
to the end
the Isis evolution makes absolute sense
right and there's probably a parable
here to in a way what's happening right
now with Turkey and the Kurds that we
were there yeah maybe we shouldn't have
been there you can make all those all
right but we were there and now we move
these troops and now turkeys just
slaughtering these Kurds and it's like
alright so maybe if we did try to go for
good reasons you know hoping that debate
aside yeah were there we know that the
Kurds were basically our allies there
and now we've left just like we sort of
left there and yeah another cars one one
America is back to defend them from all
of the other factions that are
responsibilities and all of those are I
mean I D fortunes yeah I do think it is
I mean I think people on let's call the
liberal world for is that the you we
have to have to support a lot our follow
liberals or people at least adhere to
some I mean in Kurdish factions there's
communists and there are other factions
that there are there you say liberal
just to clean up so you mean do you mean
just basic Western free people whose yes
support freedom and in general and
adhere to women's quality and all of
that so there was a funny quote that's
from from a Lebanese poet he said Sunnis
have Saudi Arabia Shias have Iran but
cigarettes have nobody but God so in a
way is that if we do not support those
who adhere to these values at least some
of them comparison to others I'm not
sure that the YPG not adhere to Western
values or enlightenment values but they
are much better than the some of the
other
factions I mean it's all by comparison
so if we're gonna let these guys to be
slaughtered then who do we have left to
support yeah I mean that is one of the
is that we need people on the ground
libertarian the purely libertarian
argument would be just get the hell out
let them do it and that's that I always
say is is that the middle east is the
opposite of Las Vegas what happens in
the middle east doesn't stay in the
middle east
yeah so you cannot leave this region
alone it's for me I mean I just came
back from Europe and I see a lot of the
refugees coming from Syria and another
war zones and this is an area that is
the central it's called the Middle East
it's in the middle of the world and it
is the birthplace of all the
monotheistic religions and its influence
on I mean it's also one of the richest
parts of the world because of oil and
natural gas and and we cannot be left
alone
and I mean the terrorists are the
extremists are not the ones leaving us
alone so the thing is that if you say
I'm gonna leave them alone it is on the
premise that there is kind of an
agreement and mutually assured
destruction here but there is not I mean
when you have a guy who wants to
establish a Caliphate and you're like no
it's not my business this is a bad deal
right but so do because the extremists
are expansionists extremists are not
gonna be happy I mean even Isis they
were not happy with just even though
they get ab large territory but they
were not happy with just this territory
they were willing to expand I mean they
have they don't get to a border and be
like alright we're going to go I mean
yeah they they are anti I mean them in
the Libertarians have a government in
which like it's a word that is
borderless is that this they they see
that their ideology is borderless which
is which is true according to their
interpretation so so yeah so so I think
is that leave them alone policy and also
it's like I mean on what privacy I mean
America has intervened in the region so
it's just like you intervene and then
you leave it in a situation that is my
break it you fix it yeah yes I do and
how to maintain all of that world order
with all of a few not gonna intervene
the Russians will not happen in Syria
and if you are gonna intervene the Turks
well and which world order you want to
live in
on the Kurds I mean they basically have
the KRG basically has a state in Iraq
yes yeah no autonomous you know if you
just before carving out that piece of
Iraq officially and just letting them
have that state I understand that you
still have the Syrian Kurds in the
church all right but do you think as an
Iraqi do you think that that basically
would just be fine I mean it sort of is
I mean I think it's all depends on what
they want I mean they're their arguments
and I and I'm happily an ally of many
Kurds and their arguments on on some
argue that we have to stay as a part of
Iraq and some of them argue that they
have to be autonomous and there are
because there's a lot of natural
resources that exist in Iraq that kind
of that they can rely on and benefit
from and also if you can afford my stage
you also might become vulnerable at
least now Iraq is a state of some sort
so that if there is a Turkish invasion
it'd still be a Turkish invasion of Iraq
in which where it's a state versus a
Kurdish state that they will be
vulnerable so there really is that true
though with the with the Iraqi army
defend you think that if the KRG the
area got attacked you think the Iraqi
army would step in
yes and maybe even the US Army right I
mean the US Embassy in Iraq is the
largest embassy in the world so so it's
still there is a special part yeah there
are still infrastructure that they can
depend on so I mean I am maybe this is
men Amman and extremist agree on it but
I am for unity if you're looking for
more honest and thoughtful conversations
about international issues instead of
non-stop yelling check out our
international playlist and if you want
to watch full interviews on a variety of
topics check out our full episode
playlist they're all right over here and
to get notified of all future videos be
sure to subscribe and click the
notification bell